à la retraite Versailles s'est fait
entendre aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la
8ème journée de mobilisation contre les
réformes des retraites après une
première manifestation le 16 février
dernier les syndicats se sont donnés
rendez-vous une seconde fois devant la
gare de Versailles-Chantiers on va aller
manifester jusqu'au gris du château avec
notre détermination et notre dignité de
travailleurs pour aller montrer qu'on
ira jusqu'au bout qu'il vote qu'il vote
pas 49-3 ou pas nous ne sommes pas
prisonniers de l'agenda parlementaire
notre agenda c'est l'intérêt des
travailleurs au total 350 personnes se
sont mobilisées une vingtaine
d'agriculteurs étaient présents à leur
côté le modèle le mouvement de défense
des exploitants familiaux et la
Confédération paysanne ont distribué
gratuitement deux tonnes de nourriture
aux manifestants objectifs faire preuve
de solidarité pour leur permettre
d'aller jusqu'au bout du combat montrer
que les travailleurs de la terre que
sont les petits moyens paysans même le
même combat que les salariés de France
pour effectivement avoir à la fois une
recette une retraite descente mais une
retraite à 60 ans qui sont largement
mérités après 40 ou 45 ans de travail
pour soutenir le cortège plusieurs
hommes politiques ont également fait le
déplacement
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
le fameux corps ce gouvernement ferait
mieux d'écouter les corps de ces hommes
et de ses femmes abîmées par des années
des années de travail sur les chaînes
d'ateliers ou dans les champs c'est un
beau symbole de se retrouver ici à
Versailles là où la monarchie a été
abolie là où la République est née et
puis c'est le rassemblement des paysans
des Métallos des cheminots des
énergéticiens ceux qui nous nourrissent
comme ceux qui font tourner l'industrie
font retirer cette réforme exiger de
tous les travailleurs et travailleuses
qu'il fasse deux ans de plus c'est
insupportable les gens ont des métiers
difficiles ou des métiers pénibles pour
la plupart des gens ce sera tout
simplement pas possible de travailler
deux années de plus la commission mixte
paritaire c'est quant à elle accordait
cet après-midi sur le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
le texte doit encore être soumis jeudi
au vote du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale